[Musique]
il ya quelque chose que je trouve assez
terrible tech on passe une année à rêver
de vacances on y va on vit une vie
complètement différente on se sent bien
et puis une semaine après ce qu'on a
vécu tous bien être qu'on a ressenti les
oublier et puis on attend avec
impatience les prochaines vacances et je
trouve ce côté un peu bull
assez assez cruel break n'a besoin pour
que ce soit vraiment l'enfer de pouvoir
rêver au paradis et bien avec les
vacances un peu le même principe et
l'idée de cette séance d'hypnose 7 vous
permettre d'importer bienfaits des
vacances dans votre vie courante pour
vous sentir bien pour vous sentir calme
pour être joyeux et puis pour être
finalement le meilleur vous même que
vous pouvez être en vacances dans votre
vie de tous les jours en revanche c'est
quelque chose qui se travaille donc
essayer de le faire tous les jours peu
importe qu en ce sens du pause
et puis si vous voulez avoir des mp3
gratuit sur sur l'hypnose et puis
d'autres exercices vous avez le site 6-4
point fr
ma chaîne youtube slash haye coaching
vous retrouverez toutes les vidéos et
puis surtout surtout le site du figaro
live où vous retrouverez toute cette
collection de
vidéo d'hypnose pratiques pour vous
aider dans votre vie de tous les jours
pour des choses aussi simples que son
dormir se relaxer arrêter trop pensé ne
pas procrastiner s'était emporté au
lendemain les choses enfin des choses
vraiment très très pratique et j'espère
qu'elle qu'elle vous plairont donc si
vous êtes prêt chez vous inviter à vous
installer confortablement
c'est une séance d'hypnose comme toutes
les autres séances d'hypnose qu'on peut
faire ah si si vous le préférez ou bien
allongé ça n'a aucune espèce
d'importance
et puis simplement commencer à écouter
ma voix à vous laisser un petit peu
porté cette fois ci un peu un peu comme
si je tue vous raconter une histoire un
peu comme si j'allais vous faire voyager
dans dans votre imagination et ça va
être le cas
et puis vous n'avez absolument pas
d'effort à faire seulement à écouter ma
voix et les moments vous décrocherez
bien ressembleront beaucoup assez ces
moments de vacances justement où une
certaine manière on oublie tout des
soucis de sa vie et on se prend à rêver
à décrocher c'est peut-être ce qu'il ya
de meilleur dans les vacances et c'est
un peu d'oublier sa vie et est
d'imaginer ce qu'elle pourrait être
alors simplement fixer un point le but
c'est vous permettent de vous focaliser
de vous concentrer mais avec douceur
facilement et comme tu le disais est
absolument rien à faire alors cette
séance est enregistrée mais ces mères en
binaural donc si vous pouvez utiliser
évidemment des des écouteurs ce sera
plus agréable vous sentirez vous
entendrez ma voix tantôt vous parlez à
gauche je t'entends vous parlez à droite
et cette proximité de la voie cette
présence presqu'en en trois dimensions
vous permettre de décrocher davantage et
aussi de d'avoir un côté bien plus
immersif dans l'expérience que vous
allez faire
vous pouvez si vous voulez noté roy sans
votre stress et comme cela après la
séance
observer cette belle diminution du
stress que vous aurez et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ce bien-être que
vous avez en vacances vous allez
apprendre à le construire
donc votre vie de tous les jours et vous
verrez ce n'est pas si compliqué donc
fixer un point vous le regardez avec un
regard doux et simplement vous écoutez
m'avoir vous laisser porter par elle et
peu importe le temps au moment où vos
yeux se fermeront pour entrer en transe
ça peut être au chiffre 5 ça peut être
au chiffre 1 dans le décompte que je
vais faire et de toute façon vous allez
pouvoir parvenir à un état de bien-être
que vous touchez du doigt en vacances et
parfois malheureusement vous oubliez le
reste du temps 5
vous entendez ma voix sa présence
et puis simplement le fait de d'écouter
ma voix permet votre inconscient de vous
indiquer la direction de la détente
vous pouvez observer comme une sorte de
d'intériorisation le regard se tourne
progressivement vers l'intérieur
et ça passe par des choses subtiles au
départ toute simple si c'est la
respiration qui devient plus lente et
c'est aussi c'est aussi les sensations
du corps tout toutes les sensations du
corps du simple contact de l'air entre
le visage aux contres les mains ou les
sensations du poids du corps la
sensation peut-être d'un léger
engourdissement quelque part une
relaxation qui progresse à son rythme
sans que rien ne presse donc rue
l'hypnose c'est un chemin vers soi même
vers la détente vers le bien être et
puis ici en quelque sorte un moment de
vacances de vacances face à ces pensées
de vacances passé sa vie un moment de
bien-être que vous accordez d'ailleurs
pourquoi ne pas vous accorder ce moment
de bien-être tous les jours pourquoi
avoir seulement un vrai bien-être une
fois ou deux fois par an en vacances
pourquoi ne pas simplement apprendre à
en avoir un peu chaque jour de donner à
sa vie progressivement aussi les atouts
des vacances alors vous pouvez observer
cette évolution progressive du corps et
puis tout simplement faire ce dernier
effort
comme un préparatif pour le voyage ça va
pouvoir prendre deux inspirations
profondes et après vous laisser porter
par le souffle pour aller de plus en
plus vers vous même j'aime bien cette
idée de voyage intérieur
parce que pendant que vous pensez
s'accroche se décroche et bien vous
entrez de plus en plus on vous même et
c'est comme un voyage on part on part de
l'extérieur et puis on se dirige de plus
en plus vers l'intérieur
on part d'un niveau de conscience des
verts un état plus inconscients plus
centré sur l'imaginaire sur le ressenti
on part donc de l'extérieur de ce que le
corps observe vers la réalité intérieure
du corps et c'est pour ça que notre
respiration devient plus profonde c'est
pour ça aussi que dans ce trajet que
vous observez celui de l'air que vous
inspirez encore une fois comme une sorte
de chemin de voyage ces terres qui se
diffuse donc vos poumons c'est comme des
racines de cam ou comme un chemin de
bien m'être qui s'installe en vous
importe l'image qui voeckler a davantage
et progressivement le corp abandonne les
tensions de l'extérieur pour ce centre
est de plus en plus vers un voyage
intérieur progressive
et ce qui était agréable avec l'hypnose
c'est que d'une certaine manière on
voyage toujours en première classe
c'est à dire que il ya absolument rien à
faire c'est à moi de vous accompagner de
séance en séance
c'est à moi de pour permettre de
développer en vous ce cas mais surtout
de savoir vous diriger vers lui
de plus en plus il ya une raison pour
laquelle tout à l'heure je vous invitais
à noter votre niveau de stress c'est que
justement j'ai envie que vous puissiez
voir quel point vous savez déjà on vous
même être calme de plus en plus calme et
la respiration devient plus profonde
plus régulière
alors que le voyage vers l'hypno
s'installe de plus en plus que le trajet
se poursuit et pour sentir ce mouvement
de l'extérieur vers l'intérieur
vous pouvez observer tout simplement le
poids des mâts le poids des gens le
poids du corps un peu comme s'il fallait
endormir le corps pour laisser à
l'inconscient la classe de se développer
de s'installer le corps loue l'esprit
qui s'allège la détente et dans ce même
mouvement l'esprit qui s'allège paul et
c'est encore la lourdeur la lourdeur de
la transe on compare souvent
l'hypnose un sommeil mais parfois on
compare aussi un voyage un peu comme si
vous preniez un escalier et pourquoi pas
laisser votre inconscient vous faire
imaginer vous faire vivre surtout
un bel escalier et commencer à le
descendre et observer marche après
marche comme le corps à devenir un peu
plus long mais respiration un peu plus
lourde eca vous descendez marche après
marche alors que vous commencez déjà à
voyager sur le territoire de
l'inconscient c'est escaliers nez de
votre imagination comme un petit miracle
qui s'ajoute la réalité vous le défendez
et comme dans l'hypnose les choses que
l'on imagine que l'on vit non beaucoup
plus de pouvoir des feux et bien à
mesure que vous le défendez vous pouvez
observer le corps qui se détend le corps
plus calme
bien être parce que votre trans l'état
hypnotique cet état de grande douceur
que vous ressentez s'approfondit marche
après marche de plus en plus de plus en
plus car c'est très bien fait de plus en
plus en transe trois semaines me
rappelle
l'histoire du voyageur qui ré achat si
loin du ont fini par s'oublier lui-même
[Musique]
où notre histoire
j'aime beaucoup une histoire qu'on
trouve dans le cas un recueil de
nouvelles de buzzati
c'est toi un homme qui toute sa vie
parcourt le monde en bateau à la
recherche d'une perle diamant d'un
trésor
et dans ce voyage ce voyage de toute une
vie il est bizarrement poursuivi par un
requin et ils essaient toujours de le
distancer
alors ils voyagent ils voyagent de
recherche quelque chose qui n'arrive
jamais à trouver et à la fin à la fin du
voyage que celui d'une vie le requin lui
dit cette chose un peu énigmatique
j'avais un trésor pour toi un diamant
d'éternité mais il est trop tard alors
pour qu'il ne soit pas trop tard parce
que votre inconscient c'est qu'il est
temps pour vous d'être bien et si vous
porter par le calme accordé dans votre
vie une place pour la sérénité pour le
bien-être arrêtez de tout le temps
bouger et prenez le temps tant le temps
de prendre votre temps de ne rien faire
peut-être bien oh pas toute la journée
bien sûr mais
une fois par jour mettez-vous en
vacances soyez en vacances
quelles que soient les difficultés de la
vie
quel que soit l'instant quel que soit le
moment
vous retrouverez dans l'hypnose un
voyage sur vers le bien-être à mesure
que vous entrez de plus en plus en
transe 2 alors que vous pensez
s'accroche et se décrochent s'accroche
et se décroche alors que faire ce
faisant se faire naître rien d'autre que
ce que l'on s'est fait alors même que
vous savez déjà plus que vous ne saviez
que vous serviez un les yeux fermés
maintenant s'il n'était pas déjà
vous êtes dans une transe agréable ce
qu'il ya de plus beau je pense dans le
voyage est vraiment réussie c'est quand
sans comprendre pourquoi
de retour dans votre vie habituel vous
avez changé
vous avez évolué et pendant que vous
pensez s'accroche et se décrochent il ya
dans tous les voyages quelque chose d'
initiatives parfois plus important dans
un voyage que dans un autre chaque
voyage vous change un peu mais certains
voyages ou changent complètement et vous
progresser vers qui vous êtes vraiment
vers ceux qui vous correspond le plus
et dans les changements de climat de
culture de bruit d'odeur les changements
de monde qu'apportent les voyages c'est
une distance par rapport à votre propre
vie que vous prenez et que vous pouvez
importer dans votre quotidien
oui j'ai ce n'est pas ce fuir
voyager c'est se retrouver se retrouver
de plus en plus en transe comme vous le
ressentez et dans ses voyages intérieurs
que tout le monde fait car qu'est ce que
l'esprit si ce n'est une manière à
l'intérieur de soi de construire une
miniature du monde extérieur mais une
miniature changé par sa personnalité par
son regard
chaque monde intérieur est différent et
pourtant chaque monde s'inspire de
l'extérieur du monde en soi qui n'est
pas le même que le monde pour son
et entre cette présence au monde je
dasein comme dit c'est changement sa
perception donc entre le monde pour soi
et le monde en soit entre ce que l'on ne
sait plus de pas reconnaître
est ce que pourtant nous perçoit
intimement et formidablement soit
mettant instinctivement aux frais est
bon ont cette capacité oublier trop
souvent cette capacité à entrer en
transe
l'hypnose est un voyage vous le savez
consciemment mais maintenant vous le
percevez inconsciemment à mesure que
vous dirigez de plus en plus en roumain
de plus en plus qu'à et c'est très bien
ainsi
séquelles
vers de jeu là kim du bellay qui ont été
repris par brassens est que j'aime
j'aime sévère je me suis quand même
j'aime cette première strophe
heureux qui comme ulysse a fait un beau
voyage
c'est le titre du poème heureux qui
comme ulysse a fait un beau voyage comme
celui qui a conquis la toison et puis
retourner plein d'usagé raison vive
entre ses parents le reste de son âge
autant dire de manière plus admirable et
touchante la réalité de ce qu'est le
vrai voyage
le vrai voyage c'est celui qui vous
permet de profiter davantage de votre
vie qui vous révèle finalement ce qu'il
ya de beau de grandes intéressant de
personnel dans votre vie ce qui vous
importe vraiment c'est ça le vrai voyage
c'est le voyage qui pousse un voyage
intérieur
mais avant de commencer ce voyage
j'aimerais que votre esprit inconscient
ou fasse vivre quelques moments les plus
doux ces dernières vacances qu'ils vous
fassent vivre ces moments vous avez eu
cette sensation merveilleuse la fois
d'être libres d'être heureux d'être bien
ce moment où l'esprit s'est mis lui
aussi en vacances
et où votre corps entier devenu au
säntis vous avez senti comme une sorte
de connexion avec l'endroit où vous
étiez ces moments précieux peut-être
fugace et précieux malgré tout et
j'aimerais que votre inconscient
prennent deux minutes pour vous les
faire revivre et quincy s'installant
vous ce que les vacances apporte de
précieux à l'âme des images les sons les
sensations vont se préciser
et vous allez pouvoir entrer toujours
plus avant
dans cette expérience de vacances ce
ciel si particulier le soleil de ses
auteurs
ces images et surtout ses sensations
intérieur que vous ont procuré ce voyage
vont reprendre à nouveau former vie pour
vous il va y avoir comme une sorte de
double mouvement
un mouvement qui va permettre de faire
réapparaître les images les sons
peut-être même touché les odeurs ou le
goût de ces vacances de ces moments
précieux bien notre mouvement celui ci
un mouvement intérieur qui va
réinstaller en vous cette sérénité toute
particulière propre à vous reprendre à
caen ce qu'intuitivement inconsciemment
vous recherchez toujours et qui cette
fois va pouvoir fleurir tout simplement
en vo à mesure que des images les sons
les sensations se préciseront
l'imagination n'est pas le lieu de
vacances du pauvre l'imagination c'est
le lieu de vacances du sage
alors laissez voter des vacances
par la magie de l'inconscient et de
l'imagination par la force que dans
l'hypnose à votre vécu intérieur les
scellés s'installer à nouveau en vous
soutiens ne vaut le contact de l'air si
particulier d'alors ressentais un
nouveau la posture les mouvements que
vous faisiez ou au contraire
l'immobilité ressentez les odeur si
particulière
la couleur même de la lumière il hebri
si différents des bruits du quotidien
fur et à mesure se construit en vous
cette expérience de vacances
l'expérience de ce qui est essentiel est
essentielle pour être bien
très bien et c'est tout cela remonter en
vous et s'installer
et pour que ce coup de vacances soient
toujours disponibles en vous je vous
invitais à faire ce que l'on appelle un
ancrage c'est à dire tout simplement de
serrer par exemple pouces contre l'index
de serrer le poing ou un autre geste peu
importe
chaque fois que vous ferez ce geste
ce sera cette même relaxation ce même
bien être au goût si particulier
teinté de vos expériences et de votre
personnalité qui se réinstallera au
temps présent un moyen pratique de
s'échapper vers soi même dès que l'on en
a besoin moyen pratique pour biais le
stress et laisser un calme souverain
s'installer en vous vous allez garder
garder cet ancrage et maintenant votre
esprit inconscient va vous faire vivre à
l'avant ce à quoi ressemblera votre
quotidien
lorsque vous le vivrai avec le même
sentiment avec la même légèreté aux
profondeurs avec la même liberté avec le
même bien n'être que vos vacances et je
vais laisser votre esprit inconscient
encore de longues minutes pour vous
faire ressentir au travers d'exemples
précis de votre quotidien
de quelle manière vous allez pouvoir les
changer en chansons vous même je vous
accompagne un silence afin que l'esprit
des vacances se posent sur le travail se
posent sur les obligations de la vie que
le temps doux que le temps que le temps
calmes infuse votre quotidien que cette
sérénité dont vous êtes capables se
précise de plus en plus et plus vous
ferez cette séance de jour en jour
chaque jour cette serre pour que se
construisait le calme et le bien-être de
vos vacances d'elle une graine qui prend
de l'ampleur qui germe qui se développe
se transforme en plan défini par fleury
que fleurissent en vous le calme des
vacances dans le quotidien de nos vies
je vous accompagne en silence maintenant
l'inconscient par lui-même à son travail
de changement
à bien
comme vous le savez les vacances c'est
aussi un lieu de liberté un lieu
d'autorisation comme si pendant un temps
on s'autorisait être libre à faire ce
qui nous convient vraiment être qui nous
sommes vraiment alors que le reste de
l'année serait finalement le territoire
des contraintes des obligations de la
frustration en quelque sorte
n'est ce pas une sorte de construction
mentale
qu'est ce qui nous empêche tout au long
de l'année de nous faire plaisir
d'exercer notre liberté
alors bien sûr il ya la force de
l'habitude il ya cette croyance que il
ya un temps pour le travail seulement et
un temps pour le plaisir
il ya cette croyance aussi que le
travail doit forcément passer avant le
plaisir mais il ya toujours du travail
alors que reste-t-il du plaisir et si on
ne se fait pas plaisir si on ne se
repose pas sera ton capable d'aller loin
est ce que cela vaut la peine d'aller
loin si l'on n'est pas heureux j'aime
beaucoup ce dicton qui veut aller loin
ménage sa monture
si vous voulez que votre monture est
loin il faut lui donner le temps de
boire de manger se reposer d'observer
les paysages d'être rude avancé de
cheminée votre vie n'a pas
séparés en deux on vous avez le droit de
cultiver chaque jour des moments de
plaisir des moments de repos des moments
ça un peu des moments de sérénité et de
faire encore plus rire le week-end des
moments de bonheur comme autant
d'étincelles de vacances que votre
quotidien deviennent jour après jour un
peu vos vacances et vos week-ends des
étincelles de vacances je vais demander
à votre esprit inconscient de choisir
l'une des choses que vous préférez dans
vos vacances plutôt d'en choisir 3 4 dès
qu'il leur a fait une fera un petit
signe peut-être on le vend 1 doivent
d'être hochant la tête
même si c'est bien et maintenant je
demandais à votre esprit inconscient de
transposer cette chose que vous aimez
dans les vacances dans votre vie
quotidienne
d'abord du lundi au vendredi et ensuite
de le transposer peut-être de la même
manière ou d'une manière plus intense où
différentes le week-end et qui leur a
commencé à vous faire vivre à l'avance
ce que ce moment de vacances va apporter
à votre vie présente nous refera une
signe oui c'est très bien et je vais
vous laisser à nouveau deux minutes pour
que se précise se fortifiait vous et
s'installe
ces moments de vacances dont deux
semaines puis vos week-ends s'accompagne
d'un silence
très bien retrait bien je vous invitais
à refaire cette séance tous les jours
parfois pour que le calme qui se
développe au travers d'elle s'installe
de plus en plus vous puissiez apprendre
à être calme et aussi pour que vous
puissiez installé dans votre vie de
nombreux aspects importants primordiaux
de vos vacances
il n'y a rien de dérisoire dans les
vacances c'est certainement le moment où
se rapproche le plus de soi même le
moment où l'on vit le plus en vérité
c'est quelque chose de précieux
alors je vous invite à travailler dessus
jour après jour mais comme vous le voyez
c'est un travail fort agréable que celui
de l'hypnose
alors il me reste à compter de 1,5 pour
vous faire sortir de transe si vous
préférez vous endormir à partir de là
vous ne pourrez très simplement pas
attention j'ai 5 à 5
sortir et de transe ou vous dirigerez
pas le sommeil profondément cannes avec
le sentiment d'avoir en vous une partie
du soleil des vacances qui brille de
plus en plus qu'elle conçoit les
facettes qu'elle conçoit les aspects
vous pouvez si vous le souhaitez pour
rediriger vers estime maintenant sinon
restez en temps mais aux endormi de un
peu plus ici et maintenant
ou sinon toujours là bas dans les
vacances de l'esprit calastreng trois
cadres dont fait ça avec ce choix soit
rester dans ces vacances de d'esprit
sept ans soit de reprendre avec un
sentiment différent et un calme profond
un nouveau rythme dans votre vie